Once you publish your app
to a distribution platform,
the first thing that people will
notice is your game icon and name.
Let's focus on the name first.
Choosing your name strategically affects
where your game appears in search
results, and can help you stand
out from your competitors.
Here are a few tips to consider
when you're thinking of a name.
Keep it short and simple.
Make it descriptive and make it unique,
which will make it easy to search for.
Each app store has a maximum app
namel length, before it cuts off and
turns into ellipses.
As you can see in this example,
Angry Birds Star Wars, and
Kingdom Rush Frontier are cut off.
So make sure to keep your name
short enough to make it visible,
especially the parts of
the names that are descriptive.
Having a descriptive name is
really important because then,
when someone browse the app store,
they'll have an idea of what your game
is about, right when they see it.
Here the name, Stack the States and
Table Top Racing give us an idea of
what to expect in the game, even if
we've never heard of them before,
a stacking game and a racing game.
You also want to have
a searchable game name.
One that sets itself apart
from any similar apps.
If you don't, you might end
up with too much competition.
Like in the case of names that
involve flappy in their title.
After the success of Flappy Bird, so
many other flappy apps popped up that
it was hard to tell one from the other.
So choose a unique, descriptive,
and short game name.